he had his [__] ice creams right and
everything was fine and then he saw
someone say something online and that's
when he realized the countryside is
racist isn't this the most racist
article ever the English Countryside
still feels like a white middle class
car but we can and we'll change it this
is Dan Guthrie he's he's got is that the
new rainbow flag mate probably he's
wearing yeah the sunset rainbow yeah my
maternal grandparents moved from Jamaica
to Stroud as part of the Windrush
movement I'm proud to still live here
that's good that's nice that's great
yeah a Government Review in 2019 founder
I'm not alone in thinking this oh my God
many black Asian and ethnically diverse
people reportedly viewed the countryside
as an exclusive mainly white mainly
middle class Club there is no [__]
fee you just get in your car you drive
over there you get out and you go oh
it's a bit green and it smells of sheep
[__] yeah now I'm going home to
civilization right that's the way to
enjoy the countryside exactly you don't
have to pay for it there's no entry
there's no one [__] standing outside
the M25 just like catching ethnic
minorities and sending them home yeah
back to London there's the the clan arm
blocking entrance to a field we're
burning crosses are they well they
aren't America mate yeah probably
[__] this is a thing and this is
actually where he just shows he's
talking bollocks in this article and
I'll point out to you why Anton bring it
up again please
they view the countryside exclusively
mainly white mainly middle class club
actually poverty in the countryside is
very frequently and in case many cases
worse in the countryside than it is in
India yeah but these people who've never
been to the countryside they live in
London they've never left and when some
idiot calls them up and goes do you feel
scared of the countryside oh yes it's
racist
they've never been outside
we live in Croydon
I mean that's they were born in Croydon
they're going to die in Croydon yeah I
mean there's plenty of wildlife in
Croydon mates so they don't need to go
to bed yeah but it's [__] armed
anyway let's keep reading I don't
understand what do we all need together
and Chip and for a prayer of walking
boots for all the big black and brown
people is that what is that what's going
on here
because I'm pretty sure they're going to
be fine they're human beings just like
you who can go into a shop by the gear
and go to the countryside isn't this the
most racist article ever do you know
it's actually a lot and it is obviously
a lot of bollocks right because poon
poon loves doing country walks she's
been to Scotland she's been all over and
she said people couldn't have been nicer
to her more welcoming more opening we
went everywhere I mean apart from like
you know we went to the West country and
they just were weird but that's because
they're they're weird they're weird to
everyone yeah but they're in bread mate
it's not their fault I got The Jug the
first time and I skipped over it because
I thought it was on the knuckle and I
thought I'd soften it by saying then
they're not nice to anyone they're in
Brave
they don't react remember it's hard
doing live stand up shout the punch line
it's the only way they're going to
understand
Vindicated
let's read a little bit more because
you've got to get the [__] article
in into the 10 to challenge this
perception of the countryside as an
exclusively white area the independent
cinema office and the Lux Arts agency
have commissioned the program called
right of way to show alongside archival
shorts exploring the history of the
National Trails my film black strangers
shouldn't be capitalized yeah it should
be
um but maybe she's racist follows my
attempts to search for an 18th century
namesake of mine the monominous Danielle
who was buried in nearby nymphs field on
the 31st of December 1719 and was
described on records held in
gloucestershire archives as being simply
a black stranger
this is going to attract black people to
the countryside
and to hide this for a second I have a
different idea for you Pricks of the
Arts agency show people the countryside
it looks nice I'm gonna be honest with
you right I show them a video of [__]
people walking and having a good time
no one's walking a good time when
they're walking in the country so I
might you just trade in sheep [__] no
you you were just a London boy you don't
like going outside the M25 yeah right
but actually walking a sheepsheet sheep
[__] is a British Pastime and a
tradition
they should be respected
my point is right
show them the [__] pictures of the
countryside it looks nice exactly and by
the way most Bulls are black so ever
think
what were you gonna say
I can't remember you were going to say
if we're going to be honest or something
like that well if we're going to be oh
no I can't remember I can't remember if
we're gonna be honest but all you see in
the countryside are animals and I've
never known an animal to be racist I'm
playing apart from my mum's old dog you
get racist dogs yeah yeah and that of
mine had a racist dog yeah yeah they'd
go a black man kicked it once and they
would just bark at black people and on
yeah there you go
I I mean it was a white dog yeah so he
hadn't you know all the programming yeah
white supremacy he had all that yeah I
made the film so basically this is just
a glorified advert for your [__] film
I made the film in the aftermath of my
involvement with a council-led
consultation in Stroud do you know what
that sounds like Star Wars mate that
sounds like that just sounds like Peak
drama a council-led conversation in
Shroud that among other things ask for
people's objection opinions of an object
in the town called the black boy clock
oh my God shroud's consultation Drew
media attention from Outlets across the
political spectrum and ignited a
cultural debate this naturally dredged
up the same tight arguments again and
again with comments such as go back to
where you came from yeah I already said
I go back to London and shut the [__] up
yeah and stop stirring up trouble around
here reinforcing this outdated concept
that people of color don't belong in
rural areas no no no no that's not what
he was reinforcing he was reinforcing
the concept that people need to stop
[__] whining and enjoy the
countryside without thinking about race
every three seconds but the official
survey found that 79 of people thought
the clock should be removed with the
words comfortable ashamed and angry
occurring most frequently when asked to
describe it
I got involved with the consultation
because the town means a lot of times
I'm sorry and to hide this person Are
you seriously telling me that 79 of
people in Britain are ashamed and angry
at the fact that a clock the black boy
clock exists somewhere in the country
did you see the the 79 are ashamed and
angry did you really did you see that
road in haringey was a famous road
called a black boy Lane yeah there's a
black boy Hill in Bristol no but they
changed it I know to what I can't
remember what it's called version of
color no no they chose something like I
don't know whatever it is but and uh you
know everyone who voted for it
practically they were all white of
course black people like oh I couldn't
give a [__] mate I'm trying to pay my
bills
79 of people are ashamed and I I am
sorry I am calling [__]
how many times have you been ashamed or
angry at any monument that you've seen
in this country am I I'll get upset by
clocks all the time
no one cares
I'll see a clock oh that's a [__]
disgrace you could put up a statue of
Hitler in London no one would notice it
because everyone's trying to get to work
it's true
I mean a couple of people a couple of
people might notice yeah my point is no
one cares no one looks at [__]
monuments no
no no one is ashamed or angry about a
[__] clock
good point let's keep reading [__] me
I'll go involved with the consultation
because the town means a lot to me and I
haven't had sex in two years
you're not one of my earliest members of
this makes [__] sense doesn't it you
see he's just young and he's a [__]
idiot one of my earliest memories is
going on a primary school field trip up
to the local common for ice creams on
what was probably the hottest day of the
year traipsing along footpaths and over
Bridges along the way
at no point then did I fill out a place
all right so everything was great as I
got older I began to question my
surroundings in the way the children do
but it was only when the consultation
hit the headlines and the reactionary
started to rear their heads online that
I properly doubted whether I belonged in
the landscape I found myself living in
right hide the center
so here's what happened he grew up in
the countryside and everything was great
yeah and then they did a consultation
and some people online reacted to her
and that's when he knew the countryside
was racist yeah
so he lived there his lived experience
was that everything is fine
for years he lived there and had his ice
creams with the [__] son and whatever
and I will not repeat what needs no
repeating about British ice cream we've
had that conversation yeah anyway and
you all got very angry and we're not
going to go there again because you know
I'm right yeah but my point is he had
his [__] ice creams right and
everything was fine
and then he saw someone say something
online and that's when he realized the
countryside is racist this you know what
this is a thing that pisses me off is
when people go look how racist
everything is
I went online and this happened this is
how racist this country is how do you
know that the person writing the shitty
comment to you is from this country or
from the countryside
he's probably from Serbia
he uses server as a placeholder country
didn't mean specifically that any
Eastern European country
right
I mean that's fair can't argue with that
you can't the logic's impeccable
absolutely
anyway
Jesus Christ
luckily finding Daniel in the archive
squash seeks concerns he reminded me
that people of color have always existed
in rural spaces and always will so
everything's fine then yeah because you
found a dead black person
[Laughter]
mate how does this is a national
newspaper in this country how are they
running the how what how
this basically he's
he go into an argument about a clock
it went online and someone well a couple
of people write a racist comment and as
a result of the arrive race is common
they just told him to well I don't maybe
some of it was right yeah so we've got a
few racist comments and as a result of
that you can't walk in a field
in a field in which he's walked his
entire life and ate ice cream and he's
always felt accepted I just what do you
do with these people I don't know
I don't know
like
the thing is there are some racist
people in society right and there are
inequalities between different ethnic
groups yeah and there's probably things
you can do to help them yeah but I don't
think this article is doing that no is
it I don't think this guy
is helping do you think he's helping
do you think this is making Society
better
do you know what I think this is mate I
think this is a crap advert for his [__]
film about a black person who died a
hundred few hundred years ago
that's what I think this is what he
happened to be in the countryside
and in the country that was almost
entirely white was described as a black
stranger well you think if you turned up
to Africa in the 1700s and died in one
of their Villages they'd be like oh his
name was Francis James Foster
and this was his day of birth and for